holds full
power we've been doing Ikea long enough
it doesn't really matter you can do all
kinds of stuff in way light but it's not
good for so wait so I'm going to take
this partial fragment from
uhy
is I going to step in I'm going to turn
drop drop the elbow here I should be
touching in here okay this is should be
contact if you're out here and there's a
gap
um for you a
second so
you what's what's s Tony used to do when
we in
C okay
right he hold the tow
here so he go Moves In and he lets go to
the tail if he's got it wrong that will
drop okay got it right it's pined in
place okay thank
you so
here that's right so I drop
in here okay now from here I can I can
shift the posture a little bit to
pressure a bit now when you do an
outside turn you need
front front posure the front pure so I
take here I'm going to go round his
string I can't push through I to go
round so fragment of T while dropping
the elbow in here making sure I'm
contact
you I try and go blow through
this when I teach students I don't let
them I don't they just fall over for me
I don't like it so I train him to be you
know tough see with me okay so I need to
go around that so I take this stance I'm
going to go
up so cut
basically down the
okay you probably got enough time one of
those